it's been almost a year since the
pandemic dimmed the lights on stages
across
town more vegas shows are starting to
reopen as a positivity rate drops and
capacity restrictions
are beginning to ease yeah gathering
still capped at 100 people or 35
capacity whichever is lower hector mejia
live downtown where one magician
is preparing to take the stage again
finally hi hector hey hector
yeah hey there good morning ladies and
it's doing so for the first time since
the shutdown so before we go
anywhere else about this we're going to
do some magic tricks right now this is
vinnie grosso and he's going to join me
right now
so alex and bianca we're going to start
this magic trick what's step one right
now
yeah we're going to do it with alex and
bianca and hector you're going to be the
magician for this
oh you're going to take this deck of
cards okay wait i don't oh oh
okay all right fan the cards out that's
great
and and put them towards the camera and
either alex or bianca one of you if you
could go in and grab a card out of that
yeah all right
look at the card it's not like the ace
of hearts or ace of spades or queen of
queen of hearts or ace of spades is it
is the a suspect
oh my gosh wow well take a different one
that's to be too easy take a different
one
so easy okay okay okay um are you
fanning out again you got a different
card
pick out okay i'm picking a different
one just imagine
okay great and uh show that to alex
but don't show anyone else turn the card
so it's face down and
uh hector turn the deck so it's face up
okay that's great and bianca slide your
card face down anywhere into that here
all right i got it that's all right wow
this is really bad
oh you dropped a couple oh there you go
okay and toss me the deck
oh great oh perfect now oh my god
bianca some people over here in the live
studio did not see the card that you
selected so could you tell them
what card you selected the first of this
nice and loud
the second one the second one okay it
was i
picked a ace of two of ace oh no two of
spades
sorry it was early in the morning two of
spades
the two of spades yes all right if we
look through this deck do you see any
face down cards
i do see one there's one face down card
right here
and it is the two of spades
that's crazy
feels good that is
wow so you are ready to uh get back
on stage and interact with a live
audience yeah right so
right now we have a small audience about
three people right now everybody come on
cheering so you know tell us you're
really excited to get back on stage and
you know more people
are getting back to work that's the
whole point of this yes yeah yeah and
it's it's not just me it's the people
that work for the show it's the people
that work at notoriety
here in the venue it's it's a lot of
people getting back to work how
challenging has it been you've been uh
all
virtual this entire year since march of
last year right and it's
it's going to be challenged doing
challenging doing it live i mean we
won't
i won't really know till it happens our
first show is the 26th
next week next week yeah so so even with
the capacity restrictions that have been
lifted you will not be able to reach
35 capacity here with the additional
restrictions you have to be 25 feet away
from
correct so because i have to be 25 feet
away from the the first audience member
that that kills a lot of the the seats
that we would have that if we were at 35
it would be 100 so we're going to be
less than 100 still so how would you
interact with an audience being so far
away
well just like i did with bianca
she was even farther away but
they are away approximately five miles
away five miles away right
but and there are so there are things
that i'm going to do up here on stage
and there are things that are going to
happen in their seats
right right where they are so well thank
you so much for having us we'll be
posting the information on our website
eightnewsnow.com tickets on sale already
right
yes notorietylive.com all right thank
you very much
reporting live hector mejia bianca alex
back to you oh one more thing i don't
have an axe to throw
like bianca did earlier this week or was
it last week
or was it last month i don't know never
day one but you know what hector he got
it right both times
because the first time i said ace of
spades and then he was right
and then again when i picked it again i
said
two of spades you got it right i know
i'm sold i'm sold hector
even though you don't have an axe you've
got the tricks yeah good job
and thank you so much to vinnie we're so
happy you can get back on stage safely
thanks hector y'all have fun out there
definitely you're welcome
all right sure